[Musique]
ça recrute sur tv78 l'émission qui vous
parle emploi dans le département des
ivines et sur le bassin de Saint-Quentin
en iveline à chaque numéro son invité
qui vient nous parler de son secteur ou
de son entreprise qui embauche et on
vous donnera aussi des conseils pour
trouver un job et ce soir dans sa
recrute notre invité et Lisa vivoni
bonsoir bonsoir alors vous êtes
responsable recrutement et emploi AC
CRMA c'est une filiale du Group r France
KLM qui est basée à H encour est-ce
Queen quelques mots déjà vous pouvez
nous présenter l'entreprise bien sûr
donc CRMA on est effectivement une
filiale du groupe Air France KLM on est
un site en fait de de réparation de
pièces de moteur d'avion et d'autres
équipements avion frein et Arnet moteur
donc on est 360 sur site actuellement et
on est en forte croissance et c'est une
entreprise du secteur de l'industrie ça
tombe bien on va parler de ce secteur
puisqueau jusqu'au 3 décembre c'est la
semaine Semaine de l'Industrie un
événement qui a pour but de valoriser
cette filière qui représente plus de
235000 entreprises en France on présente
d'ailleurs souvent le département des
Evin comme le département le plus
industrialisé en île-defance justement
Clara de Frutos bonsoir journaliste
économique de la rédaction tv78 vous
avez sélectionné trois offres d'emploi
du secteur de l'industrie exactement une
chez Talès une chez chez heramet et une
chez JC deco donc on verra ça tout à
l'heure en fin d'émission on les
présentera effectivement tout à l'heure
dans sa
recrute et c'est une entreprise du
territoire yvelinois qui recrute on le
disait CRMA filiale du groupe Air France
KLM qui est basé à éencour Lisa vivony
alors vous commenciez justement à nous
la présenter en en sommaire on est donc
là dans la filière de l'aéronautique
vous le disiez environ 300 salariés sur
site c'est ça et 300 un peu plus de 360
aujourd'hui oui et qui représente
différentes familles de métiers c'est
assez diversifié finalement ah oui oui
complètement parce qu'on va du métier
enfin voilà après on parle des métiers
d'ouvriers qualifiés à on peut avoir des
docteurs on a plusieurs docteurs et on
fait faire donc ouvriers des techniciens
des ingénieurs des fonctions support je
vous dis des docteurs dans les métiers
surtout de la de la métallurgie docteur
en matériaux donc oui oui il y a un
champ très très large de de métier avec
différenci niveau de qualification c'est
ce que vous disz ça voilà exactement
donc nous on est vraiment spécialiste
dans tout ce qui est méallurgie de la
réparation de pointe en fait sur des
pièces qui sont donc des pièces de
moteur d'avion notamment donc on va
avoir des métiers type soudeur
chaudronier ajusteur contrôleur des
ingénieurs en matériaux en mécanique des
docteurs en Laser donc c'est vraiment
des métiers qui sont aujourd'hui ben
assez pénuriques justement et des
métiers vraiment de pointe et et
spécialisés et très très intéressant
nous voilà ce qui nous différencie de
d'un certain nombre d'entreprises c'est
qu'on est plus dans la réparation et non
pas dans la fabrication donc on n' pas
du tout de de chaîne de production
chaque pièce qu'on reçoit est différente
parce que c'est de la réparation donc
elle a pas les mêmes défauts donc ça
c'est c'est pas c'est un travail qui est
pas du tout routinier et qui est voilà
qui est vraiment intéressant et c'est ce
qui nous différencie à RMA ouais chaque
mission a finalement sa spécificité et
ça fait aussi la la richesse du métier
d'avoir différents types de
problématiques à à à régler c'est de la
réparation he vous le disiez c'est ça du
coup euh la réparation qui fait que en
fait chaque chaque jour les les
personnes qui vont travailler sur leurs
pièces ont soit des pièces de donc de
Air France de Calem et plein d'autres
compagnies avec qui on travaille et des
constructeurs directement aussi qui nous
soutraitent certaines réparations et
donc les pièces elles ont pas volé dans
les mêmes conditions donc elles vont pas
avoir les mêmes défauts donc au départ
déjà on a nos contrôleurs qui vont faire
le l'état d'entrée en fait l'inspection
d'entrée dire quel réparation sont à
faire et après c'est envoyé dans
l'entreprise dans ça rentre dans le
cycle de réparation de de de CMA et donc
ben voilà chaque personne va intervenir
à son niveau pour réparer la pièce mais
avec des réparations différentes chaque
chaque jour en fait cl vousz av une
question oui ce sont des métiers qui
sont en tension et est-ce que il y a
plus d'offres enfin que de candidats
comment ah oui aujourd'hui on est ben en
plus post covid ça enfin le secteur de
l'aéro il repart il est bien reparti là
donc on est on est en pleine croissance
nous en plus on a de plein de de clients
nouveaux et plein de de moteurs aussi de
nouveaux moteurs qu'on va réparer donc
aujourd'hui oui d'ici fin 2024 notre but
c'est de faire plus 50 salariés donc
c'est sûr que c'est pas une mince à
faaire surtout comme je le disais tout à
l'heure sur des métiers qui sont assez
pénuriques type tourneur chaudronier
soudeur où malheureusement il y a de
moins en moins de jeunes qui s'orientent
vers ces ces métiers là et du coup là
l'idée voilà c'est aussi de les faire
connaître mieux et de la Semaine de
l'Industrie c'est aussi l'occasion de de
faire ça et comment on peut l'expliquer
justement cette tension chez les plus
jeunes pourquoi les plus jeunes ne vent
pas vers ce métier bah je pense que
c'est des métiers qui voilà peuvent être
perçus enfin et à juste titre comme
peut-être difficile que d'autres métiers
donc il y a il y a les conditions de
travail après voilà nous on travaille
par exemple en 28 en horaire donc une
équipe du matin une équipe de
l'après-midi qui alterne chaque semaine
donc c'est c'est des contraintes
particulières après voilà c'est des
contraintes qui sont compensé en terme
financiers donc on essaie de voilà de de
maximiser
cette cette contrainte et enfin pas de
maxer cette contrainte plutôt mais de
compenser cette contrainte pardon et
voilà après aujourd'hui euh les les bacs
les bac pro et cetera enfin c'est des
métiers qui sont issus de bac pro ou BTS
les gens on tendance à faire de plus
grandes études d'aujourd'hui euh donc je
pense c'est aussi comme ça que ça
s'explique on parlait d'un objectif plus
50 %
de 50 salariés 50 salariés effectivement
vous faites bien de de le corriger bah
aujourd'hui combien d'offres d'emploi
concrètement vous avez sur votre site à
peu près environ alors aujourd'hui je
vais avoir environ
une petite trentaine de postes donc en
production donc les M ouvriers
techniciens donc ce qu'on disait
ajusteur contrôleur tourneur fraer et
cetera et euh une dizaine postees plutôt
ingénieur et fonction support donc ça
nous en fait 40 à peu près donc c'est
c'est des posts à pour voir dès à
présent vous avez des besoins euh
actuellement alors vous vouliez
d'ailleurs faire peut-être un focus sur
deux métiers alors qui représentent on
disait tout à l'heure la diversité de
métiers que vous pouvez offrir au sein
de CRMA alors le premier métier c'est
ingénieur méthode bah déjà qu'est-ce que
c'est concrètement un ingénieur méthode
quelles sont les missions alors le
métier de N chez nous d'ingénieur donc
ces méthodes et industrialisation c'est
euh justement donc come on fait des
réparations sur des pièces de moteur on
va avoir des des problématiques qui vont
revenir régulièrement et en fait l'idée
c'est qu'après la réparation du coup il
doit être amélioré donc ces ingénieurs
ils vont travailler à l'amélioration
continue de nos réparations à travailler
justement ce qui est intéressant c'est
qu'il il vont travailler à la fois avec
le la production avec les ouvriers en
production pour comprendre avec eux ben
quels sont les problèmes euh et puis
ensuite par rapport au à la
documentation en fait de la pièce a à la
documentation qui est faite par le
constructeur essayer de comprendre quels
sont nos leviers nos marges de manœuvre
pour améliorer notre façon de faire avec
nos moyens industriels et nos moyens ben
humains donc c'est vraiment toute cet
aspect amélioration continue euh gestion
de projet parce qu'on on répare un
certain nombre enfin un grand nombre de
pièces on a plus d'une d'une centaine de
pièces différentes donc forcément après
il c'est réparti par chaque personne a
une portefeuille de pièces qui lui est
confié donc voilà c'est vraiment
l'amélioration continue en fait de de
ces réparations est-ce que il y a des
compétences des qualifications
particulières pour accéder à à ce métier
ben ce qui va être primordial c'est
vraiment d'avoir un bagage en fait en
mécanique matériaux parce qu'on a des
pièces qui sont forcément pièces en
métal et
en matériaux du coup sinon qu'est-ce qui
va être travail pas parler anglais
d'avoir parce qu'en fait la
documentation dans l'aéronautique elle
est en anglais euh bah d'être capable
voilà de
travailler en sur plusieurs projets en
parallèle enut enfin en autonomie et en
bonne entente avec voilà la production
avec différents interlocuteurs que c'est
vraiment une fonction très transverse
dans l'entreprise donc voilà des et puis
une rigueur voilà parce que dans
l'aéronautique ce qui est primordial
c'est vraiment la sécurité et la qualité
de voilà de service donc de d'être
vraiment une rigueur à à toute épreuve
parce qu'il faut respecter la
documentation c'est vraiment obligatoire
dans dans l'aéronautique et un ingénieur
un ingénieur méthode pardon combien
est-il payé est-ce qu'il y a une
fourchette en terme de salaire alors oui
tout à fait nous chez nous les les les
jeunes ingénieurs sortis d'études don
les embouche à 38000 € et ils rentrent
dans un parcours qu'on appelle jeune
cadre en fait et qui va les faire
évoluer pendant 2 ans chaque année entre
6 et 8 % donc ça veut dire qu'en fait au
bout de 2 ans ils sortent entre 42 et
44000 € donc c'est c'est une belle
évolution quand on les booste au début
pour on les accompagne et voilà donc ça
c'est pour ur on va aborder un deè
métier avec vous CLA oui cette fois-ci
on va se concentrer sur le contrôleur de
qualité alors pareil qu'est-ce que c'est
en fait contrôleur de qualité alors B le
contrôleur qualité c'est la personne qui
en fait lorsqu'on reçoit comme je disais
tout à l'heure une pièce va faire en
fait le l'inspection la première
inspection et déterminer quels sont ses
défauts donc ça va être du contrôle
visuel du contrôle dimensionnel avec des
des moyens de mesure des moyens de
contrôle et aussi un contrôle
documentaire vérifier qu'on a bien tous
les les papiers qui sont associés à la
pièce parce que dans l'aéro ben voilà
chaque pièce elle est vraiment tracée
suivie avec son son document qui la suit
donc s'il va faire ce premier contrôle
après déterminer les réparations à faire
la pièce vaer dans les différents
ateliers faire donc ces opérations de
traitement thermique de d'usinage
d'ajustage et cetera et ensuite il va y
avoir des contrôles interopération donc
la pièce va revenir chez les contrôleurs
qui vont vérifier que les travaux ont
bien été faits les réparations ont bien
été faites et à la fin toute fin du
cycle euh valider et que la pièce est
bien réparée et qu'elle elle est
certifiée pour pouvoir être remontée
sur avion en fait donc c'est vraiment un
rôle très important dans dans la
réparation du coup que valide la
conformité de la pièce à la fin et du
coup quelles sont les les compétences à
avoir pour faire ce métier bon alors
pareil c'est vraiment rigueur respect
respect aveugle de de la gamme de
travail enfin de de la documentation de
travail ça va être pareil des
connaissances en mécanique maîtrise des
moyens de mesure moyen de contrôle ça va
être bon là voilà de compréhension de
angl techniqu parce qu'on peut aussi
avoir des documents en anglais donc
voilà une compréhension technique des
termes techniques de de l'aéronautique
et voilà idéalement une expérience voilà
en a en aéronautique parce que c'est
toujours un plus pour nous et le salaire
alors côté
contrôleur c'est voà comme je dis tout à
l'heure donc en salaire de base un
contrôleur débutant ça va aller dans les
2200 jusqu'à 3000 ou plus pour des
contrôleurs expérimentés mais à tout ça
s'ajoute ben déjà on a d'autres primes
type 13e mois type les primes d'équipe
dont je parlais qui sont d'environ 300 €
par mois pour compenser les fameux
horaires en 28 donc finalement ça ça
monte à en jeune à 32 33000 € annuels et
quelqu'un expérimenté on a aussi des
primes d'ancienneté et cetera donc on pe
avoir des personnes qui sont aujourd'hui
autour des 45 48000 € annuels mais
d'ailleurs on parla de ces deux métiers
il y a une évolution possible au sein de
de l'entreprise oui oui bien sûr on a
des personnes qui sont rentrées sur des
ateliers voilà type ajustage qui volu
vers du contrôle vers de la coordination
dans l'atelier chef d'atelier vers le
bureau technique de support à la
production enfin voilà oui nous on
valorise beaucoup la mobilité interne
parce qu'on sait que c'est important
pour pour les les salariés et que c'est
de valoriser leur voilà leur
savoir-faire ce qu'on est dans des
métiers une fois de plus de de pointes
et où les compétences sont vraiment très
importantes on va afficher peut-être le
site internet pour pouvoir postuler tout
simplement on envoie son CV sa lettre de
motivation oui alors l'idéal c'est de
d'écrire directement à l'adresse
recrutement@crma.fr tout à fait mais
sinon vous pouvez retrouver toutes nos
offres sur le le site oui sur le site
cma.fr rubrique carrière alors pour
terminer cette émission on va continuer
de parler d'industrie avec vous Clara de
Frutos vous nous parlez justement de
trois offres d'emploi en lien avec le
secteur de l'industrie on parle pas
forcément d'aéronautique mais du secteur
de l'industrie de manière générale
exactement cette semaine je vous propose
d'abord un poste de technicien RND en
chimie des procédés hydrométallurgie en
CDI chez heramet à trrappe alors en deux
mots si vous connaissez pas heramet
c'est une entreprise miniire et
métallurgique française je vous parle de
parce que en ce moment ils cherchent à
agrandir leurs équipes en cause une
usine pilote de recyclage de batterie
vient de s'implanter à trappe et donc
parmi les posts qu'il propose il y a
cette celle-ci pardon donc pour ce poste
vous devrez réaliser des études à
échelle laboratoire interpréter et
synthétiser les résultats des essais les
restituer sous forme de notes et de
fichiers de données être force de
proposition pour l'orientation et
l'optimisation des essais donc ça c'est
l'é missission quelles sont les
compétences requises alors vous devrez
savoir vous organiser et vous adapter à
de nouvelles méthodes ou procédures être
capable de travailler seul ou en équipe
savoir effectuer des tests des mesures
et des analyses et rédiger rédiger
pardon des rapports des procédures et
des cahiers des charges alors pour ce
poste vous devez être titulaire d'un Bac
+ 2 ou un un bac + 3 en chimie ou génie
des procédés pour le salaire ce sera en
fonction du profil parce que aucun
chiffre n'est indiqué alors pour la
prochaine offre on revient à éencour et
vous nous emmenez chez Talès oui pour un
poste d'ingénieur électronique en CDI
pour cette offre d'emploi vous devrez
contribuer au développement des cartes
électroniques numériques et analogiques
autrement dit vous serez amené à
participer à la conception la simulation
et la caractérisation de fonctions
électroniques d'émetteur récepteur
identifier les problèmes techniques sur
les cartes électronique et réaliser leur
mise au point élaborer une documentation
technique et assurer un support
technique pour ce poste au niveau des
compétences l'entreprise demande d'
avoir des des expériences pardon
similaires c'est-à-dire que vous devezir
déjà avoir conçu des cartes
électroniques radiofréquence hyper
fréquence vous savez valider les cartes
par test en laboratoire et réaliser des
actions de mise au point cette fois-ci
un bac + 5 ou un bac + 8 en électronique
analogique et numérique radiofréquence
hyper fréquence et demandé et pour le
salaire rien n'est spécifié sur l'offre
d'emploi une dernière offre d'emploi
vous avez choisi une entreprise à morpa
oui car là là-bas il y a JC Deco qui
recrute un électromécanicien en CDI à ce
titre les missions seront notamment de
lire des schémas et des plans mécaniques
électriques pneumatiques et digitaux
réaliser des opérations d'assemblage
mécanique faire des réglages et des
graissages analyser des pannes
éventuelles pour réparer une anomalie et
réaliser réaliser pardon des opérations
de démontage pour les compétences requis
vous devrez savoir lire des schémas des
plans mécaniques électriques et digitaux
avoir l'esprit technique et faire preuve
de de rigueur et de minutie en terme de
qualification il est simplement demandé
d'avoir un bac professionnel technique
technologique ou général et comme pour
le poste précédent aucun salaire n'est
affiché et toutes ces offres et bien
d'autres encore on peut les retrouver
sur différents sites
l'industrie-recrute.fr ou encore ce
emploi.fr de sites qui s'affiche en bas
de votre écran d'ailleurs lisavie on a
constaté que beaucoup d'entreprises ne
communiquaient pas forcément sur la
question du salaire est-ce que vous
pensez que ça peut être un frein au
recrutement de pas forcément spécifier
le le salaire sur les offres bah je
pense qu'aujourd'hui oui c'est un un
sujet qui est voilà qui est
particulièrement important étant donné
voilà enfin la conjoncture actuelle et
enfin voilà donc oui oui moi je pense
que c'est aussi bien de le faire il y a
pas de secret sur ce sujet on devrait en
parler plus plus librement donc oui oui
moi je pense que c'est une bonne chose
c'est vrai c'est une donnée qu'on a
constaté en en regardant ces offres
d'emploi disponibles sur les les sites
dont on parlait voilà c'est la fin de ce
numéro de sa recrute merci de nous avoir
suivi merci à Lisa vivoni Responsable
Recrutement emploi à CRMA ETL encours
d'avoir été avec nous merci également à
Clara de Frutos de m'avoir accompagné
pour ces offres d'emploi on se retrouve
dans 15 jours Clara pour un nouveau
numéro de sa recrute d'ici là
portez-vous bien belle soirée sur
[Musique]
tv78